المصائب لا تأتي فرادى. بعد ازمة
امدادات الغاز عبر المانيا تواجه
العسكرية بغزة يدعوت احرموت نحو
نصف مليار شيكل حتى اليوم. الصين
ازمة نقص بضائع محتملة بسبب
الجفاف في نهر الرين. فكم سيصمد
للجيش الاوكراني. الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كلفت العملية
سيطرة اليابان وتطالب بها حيث
انها مجاورة لجزيرة تايوان
حفيد ارطغرل يزعج الغرب. قالت
صحيفة فاينانشيال تايمز عن
وتنفيذ غارات بحرية لتواجه
امريكا طعنة غادرة من الخلف
الاوروبية قد تدعو شركاتها
وبنوكها للانسحاب من تركيا اذا
في محيط تايوان الى هذه اللحظة
عسكري غير معلن تمهيدا للاجتياح
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن
الاستيلاء على دفعة اسلحة غربية
وتحتوي على الكثير من الثروات
النفطية. نشرت وزارة الدفاع
لتعلق الامم المتحدة ان هذا
العمل يعتبر عملا انتحاريا. رئيس
الاسوأ فان احدا لا يمكنه منع
التلوث الاشعاعي على حد قوله
وبالتحديد في الحدود الهندية
الصينية اذ اعلن الجيش الامريكي
مراكز تابعة لقيادة الجيش
الاوكراني. جزر سنكاكو قد تشعل
وتنفذ مناورات عسكرية هي الاشرس
وقد ادخلت الصين ثاني اقوى مدمرة
هذه المناورات على شن هجمات
مضادة على الغواصات النووية
ازمة في المحيط الهادئ بين الصين
واليابان. هذه الجزر تقع تحت
لن توقف الحرب على غزة وهي لا
تخشى شيء على هذا الكبرياء
واصلت التقارب مع روسيا وذلك عقب
اتفاق اردوجان مع بوتين في
لا توقف تحرشاتها بتايوان والغرب
ينتظر طعنة غدر من تركيا وكارثة
بصواريخ المقاومة الفلسطينية
لتأتي الوسط المصرية كطوق نجاة
مشاركة نظيره الهندي في مناورات
عسكرية قرب الحدود الهندية
النووية منطقة خالية من الانشطة
العسكرية مؤكدا ان هذا القصف
الكارثة العالمية ان حدثت? الصين
تتحرش بتايوان. مناورات مستمرة
الروسية مشاهد مصورة لقصف روسي
بصواريخ جراد على اهداف تابعة
الحق اضرارا بثلاثة اجهزة
للاشعاع ومحذرا من خطر كارثة
تعميق العلاقات الروسية التركية.
ووفق الصحيفة فان الدول
تتحرش بجزيرة تايوان عسكريا
وتلوح لامريكا بعواقب وخيمة
اجراءات ضد انقرة. فهل يجرؤون
على ذلك? الاحداث والتطورات.
مسؤولين غربيين ان الانذارات
تتصاعد في الاتحاد الاوروبي بشأن
في الاجواء الدخان لا ينتهي وفي
المياه الامواج لا تهدأ. الصين
الاوكرانيسكي يدعو المجتمع
الدولي الى القيام برد فعل ضد ما
الفلسطينيون اليس لهم نصيب من
حزنك يا جوتيريش? ليصرح الجيش
والمصائب لا تأتي فرادى. سيصمد
الاقتصاد الالماني. روسيا
الطرف الفلسطيني ليملي الجانب
المنتصر شروطه وهي ان يلتزم
اسرائيل وذلك خلال يومين فقط.
لتقف القبة الحديدية عاجزة عن صد
المتحدة باعلان اطلاق النار في
غزة واسرائيل وعبر عن حزنه على
الاسرائيلي ان اكثر من تسعمائة
وخمسين صاروخا قد سقطت على
سوتشي. مضيفة ان الدول التي فرضت
عقوبات على موسكو يمكن ان تتخذ
جديدة مرسلة الى اوكرانيا وتدمير
ثلاثة مستودعات ذخيرة وسبعة
هذا الكم الهائل من الصواريخ
لنعد بالزمن قليلا. وقبل اطلاق
شركة الطاقة النووية الاوكرانية
**** باعلان محطة زابروتش
ممكن. الكارثة تقترب. في حدث
تقشعر له الابدان. محطة زبروتش
في العالم وهي تايم صفر خمسة
خمسة ذات القدرات المرعبة. حيث
من قوات حفظ السلام في الموقع
فكيف برأيكم ستكون النهاية لهذه
نووية على غرار كارثة وبعد ان
تعرض الموقع للقصف طلب بنشر فريق
النووية تحت القصف. الكريم لين
اتهم قوات كييف بالوقوف خلف قصف
وصفه بقصف روسيا الارهابي لاكبر
محطة نووية. وقال انه اذا حدث
ونقله للعلاج وكذلك الافراج عن
الاسير بسام السعدي في اقرب وقت
من اي دولة عربية. فاين حق
الجوار ودم الاخوة? يا من تدعون
العروبة. من جانبه رحب انطونيو
جوتريش الامين العام للامم
ندعم بشكل كامل جميع جهود
التهدئة ونرحب بجهود الوساطة ذات
وفلسطين. الحكومة الروسية تقول
كلمتها للعلن يجب اقامة دولة
ميخائيل بوجدانوف مع رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركة حماس اسماعيل هني.
هنا ساقف قليلا. نعم. لان هذا
التصريح صدر من روسيا ولم يصدر
هذه الصواريخ صرح رئيس الحكومة
الاسرائيلية يا ارلبيد ان حكومته
الاقتصاد الالماني بين مقصلة
الغاز الروسي وغضب الطبيعة.
الصينية والتي ستقام في اكتوبر
المقبل. يا لها الرد الماكر.
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالعمل
للافراج عن الاسير خليل العواودة
في القصف الاسرائيلي. ولو كان
هناك من يسمع صدى صوتها وانات
لهم. فقد اعلنت اسرائيل فورا عن
قبولها بالهدنة حتى قبل ان يوافق
الصين. وعلى بعد امتار من حدودها
حفيد ارطغرل يزعج الغرب من جديد.
الصين بتحرشها العسكري تجاه
تايوان وطعنة ودر امريكية بظهر
المحطة النووية واوروبا تحذر من
عواقب كارثية. وهنا الرئيس
الصلة. جاء ذلك اتصال هاتفي من
قبل نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي
وبمجرد ان دوت صافرات الانذار في
تل ابيب انقلب ليله النهار
بوتين واوكرانيا تعلن عن كارثة
نووية تقشعر لها الابدان لتستمر
وا
جراحها لصرخت وقالت.
وهنا ياتي تصريح روسي يزعج
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فبماذا صرح
الضحايا جراء اطلاق الصواريخ
العشوائي نحو اسرائيل. والضحايا
فلسطينية مستقلة وعلى حدود عام
سبعة وستين وعاصمتها القدس ونحن
قبل زفافهم باسبوع ها هي بهذه
الدموع تودع خطيبها الذي استشهد
نووية على غرار كارثة تشير نوبل
فكم سيصمد العالم.